ROMAN NURIK: Welcome to Android
Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
My name is Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi.
I'm Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today's episode
is about the beautiful
design collection
on Google Play.
And I think it was about a
month or so ago that we
released a collection on
Google Play called the
Beautiful Design collection
for summer 2013.
And this is a collection of 11
apps that highlighted some of
the best of class, or I guess
some of the best designed apps
on Google Play.
So in today's episode, we're
going to look through these
different apps on
our tablet here.
And we're going to talk about
some of the best design
details in each app.
And then I think we'll
have time to go
through all 11 apps.
And then we have a couple things
at the end that we'll
show as well.
So with that, any other intro,
guys, before we jump in?
ADAM KOCH: Nope.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I just
want to talk a little bit
about how these apps
were picked.
I think that the idea behind
this collection is that these
are applications which really
embrace the design guidelines
but also go beyond that and
really have that level above
that adds the polish that
makes it a beautifully
designed application.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
So let's see.
So the collection from the blog
post that we posted about
this collection talks a lot
about attention to detail.
And it's not really about just
getting the 80% of the app or
90% of the app looking great.
It's really just adding that
final 10% of fit and finish
and polish that, again, like
Nick said, goes above and
beyond just following the
guidelines and really kind of
stressing that every
single part of
the app must be polished.
And really, you have to think
about every single flow that
the user would go through.
And so these 11 apps we found
contain some of these
masterfully crafted
design details.
And so that's why these
were chosen.
Obviously, this is
only 11 apps.
There are tons more beautiful
apps out there on Google Play.
This is just kind of the first
set, or I guess the first
collection in this set,
in this series.
You should expect more in the
future, in the coming
different seasons, since this
is just the summer 2013
collection.
And we also wanted to mention
that very recently, there are
some other apps that have
been published.
And Matias Duarte, who's the
Director of User Experience
for Android, had this really
long Google+ post that talked
about kind of where the
guidelines sit in terms of the
design process.
How you should approach the
guidelines, what types of
decisions you should be thinking
about, where you
should begin introducing
branding and consistency and
things like that.
So while we're on the topic
of the Beautiful Design
collection--
which, again, the apps there do
follow the guidelines, but
they go above and beyond that--
while we're on the
topic of this, I think that this
post really summarizes
some of the Android Design
team's views on the guidelines
and consistency and
where they fit in.
So with that, should we jump
in with the first app?
OK.
So the first app we're going to
look at-- and so, actually,
these are the apps that we're
going to look at today.
We have Pattrn, Eye in the Sky,
Pocket, Timer, Grand St.,
Pinterest, Press-- lot of Ps--
Press, "New York Times,"
Expedia, Flipboard, and Ted.
So those are the 11 apps
in that collection.
So the first of these
is Pattrn.
So Pattrn is basically an app
that lets you look at
different wallpapers.
And actually, these wallpapers
are all pattern tiles, hence
the name Pattrn.
So they kind of tile across.
They're not just one big photo
or anything like that.
But it's really something that
lets you browse and browse
patterned wallpapers
and set them.
So we're only looking
at tablet today.
One of the key things in this
collection, actually, before
we jump in here, is that most,
if not all, of these apps are
really responsibly designed.
So this is one of the--
meaning it works on tablet, it
works on phone, it works on
seven-inch, and so on.
And so this app right now is one
of the best examples of a
very nice standardish responsive
design, where
basically on a tablet here, you
see multiple columns of
patterns, of wallpapers.
And on a phone, you actually see
fewer columns, maybe just
one column and two columns
on landscape.
And then you have your kind of
core navigation on the left.
You basically can jump in
between or switch between
different sections.
And then you can open up one
of these wallpapers.
And one of the nice touches is
that they have these very
subtle animations here that
let you see more.
And actually, it also goes
into lights-out mode.
So you actually fade out, or you
dim the navigation bar and
the status bar in the process.
And one of the last things I
wanted to mention about this
app-- and obviously the
responsive design, I think for
me, is one of the biggest
things about it
that makes it so great--
one of the last things is that
there are subtle little
touches here and there, like
letting you rotate the
wallpaper, set the wallpaper
automatically on a schedule.
And then also, just the overall
fit and finish, it
really does feel like
a really, truly
Android-designed app.
So overall, just a
very solid app.
That's the first one
in our collection.
Can we move on Pinterest?
ADAM KOCH: All right.
So let's talk a little
bit about Pinterest.
So for those of you who are not
familiar with Pinterest,
it's a social networking app
that sort of revolves around
these virtual pinboards,
where you can
pin up virtual content.
I will admit I am not a big
Pinterest user myself.
But that doesn't mean I can't
play with the app and use the
app and see how it's beautifully
designed.
So the first thing you'll
notice, and this is kind of
interesting because there's no
sort of standard action bar.
And of course, if you've
listened to any of our shows,
we're always talking action bar,
action bar, action bar.
But in this case, they've
actually gone for almost like
a hybrid between top-level tabs,
which you may see in an
app like, say, the "People" app,
and the sort of standard
action bar, where you have
branding only in the top left.
And it actually works nicely
because on their website, they
have this same design
and layout.
So you can see here, they've
still got the sort of standard
interaction patterns of swiping
between these tabs,
where the middle tab is
really sort of home
or browse your stream.
And the left tab, while it does
have a search icon, it's
more of a discover tab or
something along those lines.
And so that's the first
I wanted to call out.
The second thing is this
multi-column layout.
And that's, again, very similar
to their website.
And this is really nice because,
obviously, their
social network revolves heavily
around content, so
it's a very content-forward
design.
And it has the added advantage
that it's also very
responsive.
It scales very well to different
screen sizes.
As we mentioned before, we
couldn't show you the phone
layout today.
But you'll see on the phone
layout and on the smaller
tablet or portrait layouts,
you'll see that it reduces the
number of columns
nicely there.
ROMAN NURIK: One of the best
things about this, really
quick, is that the Chrome of the
app, the bar at the top, I
guess the action/tab bar, the
bar at the top follows the
natural Android interaction
model, but the content is very
much Pinterest.
It's very much
Pinterest-branded content, almost.
The exact layout of
the posts is very
much a Pinterest thing.
So that's one of the
ways in which they
let their brand show.
ADAM KOCH: And they've also
sort of fused their brand
design with the Holo
design language.
So you sort of see the
Holo design tabs.
You sort of see the buttons
are much flatter than what
they have on their website
and in other platforms.
They have sort of the
overflow down here.
So they've done a very good
job at the middle ground
between fusing Android design
with their own brand.
NICK BUTCHER: And just one
little thing on Pinterest.
I absolutely love the way, as
it's loading in a new image,
it'll take the average color
of the image, right?
Yeah, there we go.
So the color shown will be the
average color of the image
once it's loaded.
It's a completely unnecessary
detail that I love.
It is delightful.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's one
extra database field, but for
a lot more value there.
ADAM KOCH: All right, guys.
So that's Pinterest.
We really like the
Pinterest app.
ROMAN NURIK: Pocket?
Nick, you want to talk
about Pocket?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So Pocket, hopefully you know,
is kind of a catch-up reading
of the news sites.
So you can save sites, videos,
images, and so forth into your
Pocket and catch up later.
So when trying to pick what I
wanted to highlight in this
application, I initially
thought about
the responsive design.
Because like these other
applications we looked at so
far, this app responds
beautifully to the form factor
of the device you're
looking at it on.
So on a phone, for example,
it'll use list-based
navigation when you click
a [INAUDIBLE].
And as you get to larger
devices, it breaks out into a
grid, and then there's kind
of an asymmetric grid,
as you can see here.
If you have more content, there
would be lots and lots
at the top.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, sorry about
not filling it out completely.
ADAM KOCH: I forgot to add
it in, but that's OK.
NICK BUTCHER: No problem.
But in fact, my favorite detail,
I think, about this
application is the sheer focus
on the reading experience.
The application does a lot of
stuff, but it doesn't feel
heavy in its user interface.
Everything seems to get out of
the way in order to let you
have the best reading
experience.
So for example, the user
interface here, the action bar
and so forth, is all
quite muted.
So it immediately recedes
out of the way.
And if you could start scrolling
down through the
article, as soon as you start
scrolling-- that's a very
short article.
Were it longer, as soon as you
start scrolling down, the
action bar hides.
And once again, we go into
this, what we refer to as
lights out mode, where
the system bar and
navigation bar recede.
See the slightly dim state.
So it's all about the
reading experience.
But as soon as you start
scrolling back up, which
indicates you've finished the
article, for example, the
affordances jump right back.
So you can check the time or
multitask to another app or
use one of the action
bar options.
So it just gets out of your
way, and it just works.
And I love that focus on
the reading experience.
And the same thing's
true of their kind
of pagination model.
So you can either read it in
an endless stream, so where
you're swiping up and down.
Or you can swipe left and right
to change to a paginated
content model.
And I love the fact that there's
no-- you can imagine
that one way of implementing
that interface would be some
kind of toggle or switch or
machinery in order to do it.
But instead of doing that, they
just listen to how you're
trying to use it.
So if you scroll vertically,
then it'll give you a vertical
stream of content.
And if you scroll horizontally,
then it'll
automatically flip into this
paginated content model.
So again, it just reduces all
the machinery around it and
just really, really focuses on
getting out of your way and
letting you get to
the content.
So really, really great
attention to
detail in this app.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I'd say
that it's one of the best
in-reading experiences.
If at all, you need to build
an app that lets you read
through large chunks of content
that have large body
copy, definitely look at this
app as a shining example of
how to do that right.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, it looks a lot
different once it's filled
out with content.
We did a bad job at
prepopulating it today.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Shall we move on to Timer?
So Timer is a very,
very simple app.
It's--
ADAM KOCH: Let's start
the ADiA timer.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh yeah, sure.
So Timer is basically an app
that it's just that.
It's a timer.
It has a couple of features.
It has basically a stopwatch.
Does it have a stopwatch?
I actually don't remember.
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
ROMAN NURIK: But it basically
has a countdown timer.
It's just kind of your standard,
run of the mill
countdown timer.
But the best thing about this
is the interactions and the
little ways in which they
sprinkle Android goodness.
So for example, if you pull down
the shade here-- well,
Android Design in
Action is live.
That's good--
you'll notice that the
notification is very
customized.
And they have actions built
into the notifications.
So without even-- let's
say I'm just at
the home screen here.
I can manage my timer
right from here.
So I can pause and resume it.
I can see how much time
is remaining.
And I can obviously end
it if I needed to.
But also, one of my other
favorite things about this was
that the interaction for
creating a timer is very
simple and intuitive.
So you basically just drag
this thing around.
And sorry for the lag here.
I think our HDMI connection
is laggy.
But you basically just
drag this around.
And it's very tactile and kind
of visceral, the feeling of
rotating a dial.
It almost hints back
to the earlier
days of a rotary telephone.
So the interaction model here
is very nice, and it's also
very simple.
The last thing I wanted to point
out is that they have a
couple of themes.
And while having multiple themes
is not a necessity,
it's always a nice
extra touch.
And they also basically
theme everything.
So if you switch from the light
blue to the light orange
theme, basically everything
becomes orange.
The action bar, tabs, even the
app icon becomes orange.
So you can see here, their
single accent color changes to
fit what the user prefers.
So overall, very nice, simple
app, obviously also using
responsive design
best practices.
They have a tablet version
that works in portrait,
landscape, 7-inch, 10-inch.
So just an overall very solid,
very simple app that just gets
the job done.
I think next we have Grand St.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, just pardon
me jumping in there.
One last really subtle touch
that I really like about this
is-- and you can't really it--
is that in the actual rich
notification, they have that
same circular representation of
the timer, which actually
fills in with the color of the
theme that you chose as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
if you just do--
NICK BUTCHER: Show
the timer, maybe.
ADAM KOCH: OK, let's move on.
Let's move on.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
just do on this.
NICK BUTCHER: We could probably
use this app to make
sure we don't overrun.
ADAM KOCH: I know.
We should use it every
week, actually.
Let's leave it running.
All right.
Let's move on to Grand
St. So yeah, I'll
switch this to featured.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh no!
Ah!
ADAM KOCH: Oh, demo fail.
NICK BUTCHER: Cannot
see the demo.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
there we go.
ADAM KOCH: Demo fail.
So Grand St., for those of you
not familiar with it, is
basically a curated
gadget catalog.
And the Grand St. team goes and
finds these interesting
gadgets and then reviews them
and then posts them up through
their app and through
their website.
And the first thing you'll
notice is it's basically like
a digital magazine.
They've essentially converted
the old school version of a
physical magazine into
a digital magazine.
And you can see, it's instantly
full-screen imagery,
really nice typography.
And they've actually gone for
this sort of custom action
bar, but very much sticking to
the interaction patterns and
the layout, the sort of gist
of the regular action bar.
You can see they've got their
app icon in the top left, a
spinner next to that.
And then they've left the area
between that empty, and then
they've got the regular sort of
action items and overflow
on the right there.
I think it works really well for
taking the focus off the
UI elements and then bringing
the focus to the actual
content of the application.
So you can see here, they've
got these dots representing
the different pages
of the magazine.
And then this is one
of the products.
Let's go into it here.
And then they've got this really
nice representation of
the actual review and content.
So between each of the screens,
there's actually
these full-screen images.
And around subtle design
touches, you can see here it
sort of fades in as
you swipe out.
You can read some information
about the design and then,
again, see another really nice
full-screen image here.
And an interesting thing that we
can't actually show here is
that if you go into portrait
mode, it is a slightly
different representation where
you can view the images at the
top of the screen and then
the content below that.
Can't show that here because
we're on HDMI, and it's kind
of hard to rotate around.
And then I'm not going to talk
too much more about this
because we're low on time.
But for previous items that
they've talked about, the sort
of non-featured items, they
have this nice, clean grid
view of items.
And again, it's multi-column,
so it scales very well to
different screen sizes.
You can go back and browse all
of the previous items that
they've actually reviewed
in the past.
NICK BUTCHER: And the Grand St.
Team, actually, they had a
really nice blog post about the
iterations of design they
went through in order
to arrive here.
So if you check out their
blog [INAUDIBLE].
It's pretty interesting.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
You'll have to share that
in the comments somehow.
My favorite thing about this app
is just the complete focus
on full-bleed imagery
and typography.
And that really makes it feel
more like a magazine because
there's no Chrome
on magazines.
There's no buttons you can
press in a magazine.
It's really all content that
you're playing with.
So this really feels
like that.
ADAM KOCH: And they even go to
the point of engaging the
low-profile mode so that you're
really engaged in the
full-screen content.
All right.
ROMAN NURIK: Let's move on to
Eye in the Sky Weather.
Nick, do you want to talk
about Eye in the Sky?
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
OK, so my favorite thing about
this application is the sheer
simplicity of it and the way
it elegantly shows the
information hierarchy.
So I think they do a really,
really great job of really
picking out the most important
information and then making
the flow of that information
really obvious.
So it instantly jumps out at
you what the immediate
conditions are, and then you can
tell by the layout and so
forth what the upcoming
dates are.
I think it's a very simple
application.
There's a ton of web
applications out there.
But I think this one in
particular does a great job of
just elegantly displaying what
you need to know and putting
everything within easy reach.
Once again, it's also
another example--
I think like all of the apps
in this collection--
of great responsive design.
It'll move--
on a phone device, you'll have
these three major sections on
the left will be swipeable tabs,
and on a larger device,
at a certain point, they get
broken out into this dedicated
navigation section.
And it rearranges what we
call the macro reflow.
It rearranges the major content
blocks in order to use
the space well.
ROMAN NURIK: I also personally
love the upgrade
banner at the bottom.
It's not in your face.
You can actually dismiss it.
And I think if you dismiss
it, it shows ads.
Well, at some point it shows--
yeah, there it is.
But it's basically kind of an
unobtrusive way to hint at
other features that
are available.
Or it's like an upsell,
but it's an
unobtrusive upsell, basically.
So it's kind of a nice
way of doing it.
ADAM KOCH: I think weather
apps are actually an
interesting problem because
there's so much information
you can display.
And it's actually challenging
to get everything displaying
in a nice, concise format,
as Nick was saying.
ROMAN NURIK: Shall we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
We need to go quickly.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
What are we at?
10:48.
Ah, that's fine.
We got plenty of time, guys.
All right, next, let's
look at Press.
So Press is an app that-- let
me just go to the very
beginning here.
Press is an app that is
basically your feed reader.
Formerly, it hooked up
to Google Reader.
So it was basically a Google
Reader client.
It would show you all your
different subscriptions and
all the different articles that
you haven't read under
each subscription.
And now it supports a variety
of different services,
including Feedly, which is what
we have hooked up here.
But the idea is that it's
basically a client your
reading stuff, your
reading queue.
I would call it the
pre-Pocket.
You look at something here, and
maybe if you want to read
it later, you throw
it into Pocket.
ADAM KOCH: That's definitely
my workflow,
like press to Pocket.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
But the idea here--
the reason we like this app so
much is that it's just very
clean, again, very minimal.
It's all about content.
You can even look here.
The tabs here on the left--
actually, on a phone,
this would be one
screen here on the left.
And this would be
the next screen.
We basically have tabs
here on the left.
And the icons for the tabs
are incredibly minimal.
The filled circle means
that it's unread.
The outlined circle
means it's read.
And the star just means it's
your starred content.
So it's a very interesting
workflow.
You basically have your step
one, you have stuff that you
haven't read.
Step two is the next evolution
of that, stuff you've read.
And step three is stuff that
you really care about and
you've starred.
So the hierarchy there
is very clear.
So once you jump into a category
and then a feed--
let's look at the Verge,
for example.
Actually, yeah, the
Verge is fine.
That'll do.
ADAM KOCH: You could do all.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, let's look
at all, all subscriptions.
So you basically have this very
simple master detail flow
on the left.
And you can expand this fully.
And you have another very,
very nice reading view.
The one thing that I love about
this app is that the
typography is great.
You have lots of different
choices for fonts.
But their default choice--
I think it's Source Sans by
Adobe, looks great here.
The other thing is that there
are some variations to the
design guidelines.
So for example, if you long
press, you get this kind of
embedded contextual actions.
We generally prefer doing things
a different way, but it
is one way of doing things.
And actually, the nice thing
about doing it this way is
that it offers an in-place,
contextual kind of mark
everything above
me as red, mark
everything below me as red.
So it's almost like you have
an immediate sense of what
you're marking as red.
In general, we tend to use the
contextual action bar instead,
but this is an alternative.
And then they have nice
little touches.
You can mark something as red
here and things like that.
So overall, it's a very
well-branded app.
You'll see that the highlights
throughout are very sharp red.
And the general color scheme is
almost like USSR, like dark
gray and bright red.
It's almost a little--
not stock, but it's almost
USSR-colored.
But it's kind of cool.
It gives it a very simple,
sharp feeling.
So yeah, that's Press.
And like we said before, it's
very much following responsive
design best practices, supports
tablets, phones, all
sorts of things.
ADAM KOCH: All right,
let's keep going.
All right.
So the next up is "New York
Times." Hopefully you're
familiar with "New York
Times." it's a
very well known newspaper.
And we really like this app.
What they've done here really
is use two things which are
very sort of central, core to
the Android design guidelines,
is typography and white space,
to really show hierarchy and
also make it feel like
a newspaper.
So you can immediately see
here, the titles of each
article really jumps
out at you.
And then it's got the brief
blurb below that and then some
imagery in certain cases.
So let's have a look at one
of the articles here.
It's a very clean layout.
I also like how they've used
white space on the sides here
to bring in the margins to
make it a better reading
experience.
And as recommended, they
have this swipe to
navigate between articles.
ROMAN NURIK: The images are
really, really crisp.
So they're serving the right
size images for tablets.
ADAM KOCH: Yep.
And they've done also a great
job here of, again, merging
the brand colors.
In particular, typography
really screams "New York
Times." You look at this, and
immediately, you're like, oh,
that looks like the "New York
Times." That feels like the
"New York Times." But it also
feels very much Android, very
much Holo designed.
ROMAN NURIK: One quick thing
about typography I wanted to
mention is that in general, you
can't just throw any TTF
file at Android's rendering
engine.
Just because it may look great
on your desktop machine
doesn't mean it will look
great on Android.
Specifically, there are some
character spacing things that
come up with fonts that
aren't optimized.
So "New York Times's" font here
is specifically optimized
for mobile, so it works just
great with Android's native
type rendering system.
ADAM KOCH: Now obviously, the
focus of "New York Times" is
on text, on reading,
on articles.
But they also actually have a
really nice photos screen.
And as Roman was saying, the
images are really crisp,
really nice.
This on a Nexus 10.
They engage the low-profile mode
here so you can really
just get immersed
in these images.
And they have a similar screen
for videos, as well.
All right.
Let's keep going.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Next, we have Expedia.
Nick, do you want to
talk about Expedia?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
It's almost a shame we're
showing this on a tablet
because they have quite
different running modes on a
tablet and a phone.
And I think the phone's been
updated most recently, and it
knocks my socks off.
But the aspects of the Expedia
app that I really wanted to
call out are the elements
of fun and
whimsy which they introduce.
So if you can see here, they
have a loading spinner, which
is a hotel door hanger.
And this actually responds
to the accelerometer.
So I'm not sure if we'll
be able to show it.
ADAM KOCH: For some
reason, we can't.
NICK BUTCHER: If you tilt the
device side to side, this
swings back and forth
to remain level.
Things like that.
All the animations
are super smooth.
And one of the things the does
really, really well,
especially the phone one,
is inspire you.
So it uses imagery to inspire
you about different
destinations you might
want to travel to.
So while searching for a hotel
or a flight could be quite a
dry task, they actually really
introduce fun elements and
inspirational elements
that make the
process much more enjoyable.
You actually find yourself
really enjoying using the
application.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it
is a shame we can't
show the phone version.
On the phone version, there's
this really beautiful two-tab
system, where on the first tab,
you have this kind of
parallax scrolling list of
hotels and flights, kind of
like deals that give you some
ideas on where to go.
ADAM KOCH: And among the design
touches, as well,
there's one loading screen, I
think, where it's like an
aeroplane window, and you can
actually open the window and
close the window as well.
It's really cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if you do a
flight search, you can play
with the shade on the window.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, there
is planes.
ADAM KOCH: I'm not sure
if we can do it.
ROMAN NURIK: So not the entire
app is tablet-optimized, but
certainly this immediate
screen.
OK, so let's move on.
Just take our word for it.
Check out Expedia
on your phone.
It's really awesome.
The next app is Flipboard.
So I don't think Flipboard
needs too much of an
introduction.
But it's, again,
a very simple--
"Now optimized for Android
tablet screens.
If you prefer, you can switch
back to the phone mode."
That's fine.
So Flipboard is kind of an
interactive magazine.
It aggregates everything from
Facebook to Google+ to tech
blogs to news to things like
that and puts it in this kind
of unique UI.
And as you can see here, just
from the beginning, it
immediately starts
interacting.
It starts zooming in photos,
panning photos.
And it really is immersive.
You open this, and you really
feel like you're getting a
full view of your content.
So let's actually flip
through this page.
And actually, you'll notice that
they have this kind of
unique Flipboard interaction
that's the same across all
their different platforms.
I believe that's part of their
branding, that flip.
So if we open up one of these
items, you'll notice that it's
still very much customized.
The UI is--
again, just like some of the
other apps that we've talked
about, it's very much
about the content.
There's minimal Chrome.
It recedes, fades
out of the way.
But they are, like in Grand
St.'s case, they're using
their visual styling but
applying our interaction
design and UI pattern
best practices.
So they still have the up
button in the top left.
They still have the overflow
that gives
you additional things.
They do have this additional
option for navigation there,
but whatever.
And they do have search in the
top right, which is kind of
the standard place
to expose search.
But all throughout, their
flipping UI is still there.
And so it still feels
like Flipboard, just
customized for Android.
And then if you open up one of
these articles, you'll notice
that, again, they include large
margins on the sides.
They tweak the font sizes and
line spacing, especially, to
make sure that on a tablet,
things look great.
And they don't really have
a top action bar here.
But they do have kind of like
a split action bar.
We'll give them that.
And basically, all the actions
are available on the bottom
right, and then with an
overflow, as you'd expect.
So yeah, Flipboard, overall,
really custom visual styling,
but still following
a lot of our
interaction design best practices.
ADAM KOCH: All right.
Better get a move
on, as always.
Last is TED, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: All right.
So TED, hopefully you're
familiar with it.
They post up some great free
TED talks to inspire you.
This app actually follows
the Holo design
language quite closely.
They've just customized the
colors accordingly to fit in
really nicely with the TED
colors, which are just the
white and red.
The focus, purely on content.
You see these great big,
large video thumbnails.
Multi-column, again,
scales very well to
different screen sizes.
You can swipe between the tabs
here, between these three main
tabs, My Talks, All Talks,
and Featured.
They've got these three larger
banner images at the top here
to promote the featured
or latest.
And then again, once you're
viewing the talks, you can
swipe between the talks
very nicely here.
It's a great app.
Hopefully, a lot of you
have seen it before.
There's really not that much
more to say, other than
they've done a really good
job merging TED brand
with Android Holo.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Solid.
ADAM KOCH: All right.
We've got one more.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so those are
the 11 apps in the Beautiful
Design collection,
summer 2013.
If you just search for Beautiful
Design 2013, you
should find our blog
post announcing it.
And I think that it's currently
visible on Google
Play, if you go to Apps
and scroll all
the way to the bottom.
Now there's one more app we
wanted to talk about.
Nick, do you want to
talk about Timely?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So this is a new app that
launched just yesterday, I
think, which is an alarm
and stopwatch and timer
application.
But I really love this app.
So I think the one word which I
would use to summarize this
app is polish.
Every single thing you do
in this application
is extremely polished.
So from right here,
we can show--
so this panel on the right hand
side showing the current
time is the main display.
On the phone app, this would
be the launch screen.
And I love the way that as you
swipe between the three major
tabs, that content always
stays persistent.
So whether it's larger when
you're in the center view or
over on the side, it's a really
fun way to use the
extra space on larger devices.
But as Roman is swiping around,
you can see the
changes in the background color
and the subtly moving
background images.
Everything about this
application screams polish.
So I think one of the fun things
I like, they have a lot
of custom items in here.
So like the background, for
example, is very, very custom.
And you can even go ahead and
can tweak the colors on that,
which is kind of fun.
So if you go into the overflow
menu and change themes and
then click on that little thing,
you have this really,
really fun color picker that
lets you just completely,
completely customize this
application to whatever color
scheme you want.
And I really love the-- and I
think it's actually quite a
clever marketing idea, that
lets you do the full
customization.
But if you want to save it,
that's an in-app purchase.
So I think it's really fun to
demonstrate its value before
charging you for that.
If you want to show the
stopwatch and timer.
So for example, if you look at
the interaction used for
setting a timer--
actually, the stopwatch
is fine.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, stopwatch.
Got it.
ADAM KOCH: We're just having
too much fun here.
NICK BUTCHER: So hopefully,
the framerate
is picking up here.
But you have this almost
like a heartbeat.
You see the pulse moving around
the circle, tracking
the time as it goes up.
Little details like that,
they've gone beyond the level
of just having the
time ticking up.
They actually have these
beautiful, interactive
animations.
And if you go the timer as well,
I think very similar to
the Timer application we looked
at before that had a
very visceral way
of setting it.
But these beautifully engaging
kind of animations.
And I love the way, as you go
past the minute or hour or
whatever, how it shrinks
in and grows out.
ROMAN NURIK: Also, one of the
coolest things is that the
text actually morphs.
So 6 morphs into 5
into 4 and so on.
So I don't know how they're
doing that, but it's really,
really cool.
One thing that I wanted to
mention is that I feel like
they've done a crazy good job
of styling everything to fit
their almost transparent UI.
So even the setting screen that
you would expect to be
kind of boring has this
immersive, interactive,
animated background.
And all of the controls
just blend
beautifully on top of it.
So they've just done an insanely
good job on that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so just
animations, polish everywhere.
This app is incredibly
polished.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, they have
a lot of those subtle
animations.
NICK BUTCHER: I love
that interaction.
ADAM KOCH: Sorry, Nick.
NICK BUTCHER: No worries.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
I think that's all the
time we have, right?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, we're a bit--
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So I think that's all the
time we have for today.
Thanks again for joining.
And yeah, just one
last reminder.
If you haven't seen this
collection, if you haven't
downloaded and installed some of
these apps, definitely make
sure to do so.
Just search for Beautiful
Design summer 2013,
and you'll get there.
All right.
That's it.
NICK BUTCHER: And a challenge
to all you
designers out there.
As Roman said at the top of
the show, the plan is to
update this collection
periodically.
So we're going to cycle
out some apps,
bring in some new apps.
So this is really a challenge
for you designers out there.
This is the goal you want be
aiming for is to be getting
into this collection.
And so let's see what
you can do.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
All right, thanks, everyone.
ADAM KOCH: Thanks, guys.
ROMAN NURIK: See you later.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye.
ADAM KOCH: Bye.